Sprinting to the finish line. We're almost there. Just a little bit left to go.
Only one more slightly difficult part.
Here is findcrossword, and because I can see the finish line,
I'm not going to explain it line-by-line, but you go ahead and read it.
Two other small bits--we need this list of neighbors in the north, south, east, west order,
and we've got to be able to transpose a matrix.
It turns out that one way to transpose a matrix is an old trick.
You map list to the zip of the application of all the rows in the matrix.
If that makes your head hurt, don't worry about it.
You can play with it a little bit to see why it works or you could use this expression here--
[ M [ j ][ i ] ] for j in the range and for i in the range.
Now I'm excited to see it work. I ran it. It did, in fact, work.
Solidified the results by putting them into a test--examples of finding cross words,
finding neighbors, transpose--that looks like it works.
Transpose of a transpose--you get back what you started with.
If we set anchors on our sample board--we get back the sample row that we did by hand.
If we call horizontal plays, we get back this list now.
I feel a little bit bad here that I wrote this as a test, and yet I can't really verify
that this is exactly the right answer.
I haven't gone through every word in the dictionary to figure out if I got this exactly right.
This serves not so much as a unit test--a unit test is something that verifies
that your function is doing the right thing--
rather this serves as a regression test.
Regression test means that we're just testing it to see if we broke something.
We want to get the same result this time as we got next time
if we make a small change to our program.
We can verify that this looks reasonable--that we got the big word we were looking for,
BACKBENCH, other components of it like BENCH and then a bunch of three-letter words,
which always show up in Scrabble.
That was the horizontal plays. We can also do the all_plays.
It's gratifying that all_plays is a bit longer.
It's gratifying that BACKBENCH is still there, and when we run it, it passes.
Bird-by-bird--we can check off one more.
Now there is only one left--scoring.